cela dit ce dont nous parlons ce matin
est loin d'être interdite c'est c'est
plus que recommandée c'est une fierté de
la région et nous avions envie de vous
la présenter avec marie thérèse garcin
qu'élite conférencière aujourd'hui vous
nous emmenez haute saône dans la cité du
meuble précisément à saint loup sur
semouse s'il vous plaît pas pour parler
mobilier mais plutôt pour par les
cosmétiques avec un aventurier de la
région oui un visionnaire alors qu'elle
a un très bel homme
oui mais ça c'est la femme d'état d'août
il est fils de distillateurs de fruits
et il va aller faire des études
d'ingénieur commercial et quand la
maison petitjean donc c'est armand
petitjean la maison petitjean va fermer
va mettre la main la laque la clé sous
la porte
eh bien les enfants décident de partir
au chili donc frères ce tout le monde
paraît au chili pour ils veulent créer
une société d'import export au chili
d'ailleurs ils réussiront très très bien
c'est l'époque aussi où il ya notre
bourguignons qui est originaire de
chassagne montrachet louis joseph
bachelet qui va aussi partir au chili et
qui est l'arrière arrière grand père de
la présidente michelle bachelet l ancien
président du gie ancienne présidente du
chili donc c'est là même la même
histoire ils partent tous au chili pour
faire fortune
le problème c'est que la guerre mondiale
alors que là la guerre arrive et armand
petitjean est quand même assez
il est proche de la france il revient en
france pour faire la guerre
hélas après la guerre il est remarqué
par philippe berthelot qui est
secrétaire général aux affaires
étrangères qui va remarquer cet homme
qui a beaucoup de cas de charisme et il
va lui proposer des missions
diplomatiques en amérique latine et là
il rencontre françois coty le grand
parfumeur et qui va lui demander de
gérer son établissement au brésil en
parle de françois coty le grand
parfumeur parisien parisien voilà au
prince mais on est loin de la bourgogne
franche comté
oui alors pour la voilà donc françois
coty va recruter
armand petitjean notre franc comtois et
il va lui proposer de gérer son
entreprise à rio de janeiro et après il
le fera venir à paris où il va gérer la
maison coty si je comprends bien au
départ il est diplomate
donc voilà il y avait là des missions
diplomatiques la mission d'informatique
il est loin de la parfumerie se retrouve
chez un parent fumeur mais alors
pourquoi ils se retrouvent sur un
parcours parce qu'il a du nez ou quoi
exactement à ce moment là quand il va
rencontrer françois coty il découvre
qu'il a un nez alors c'est un fait
en parfumerie donc l'élément
indispensable pour la création de parfum
donc françois coty va immédiatement le
recruter et quand françois coty va
décéder en 1934 et bien armand petitjean
notre franc comtois décide de quitter la
maison coty et de créer sa propre
entreprise c'est cette entreprise qui
s'appelle lancôme voilà c'est de ça dont
nous voulions vous parlez ce malade
c'est long comme à l'origine en
bourgogne sont connus dans le monde
entier
alors pourquoi lancôme pourquoi prend
t-il ce nom de lancôme
parce qu'il s'est inspiré de ce château
qui se trouvent dans se trouve dans
l'indre et qui s'appelle lancôme mêlant
comme lan ses os et lui il va supprimer
le s muet pour le mettre un accent
circonflexe comme l'écriture ancien le
vieux français du chic à la française
voilà ça fait chic ça fait plus il ya la
place vendôme avec tous les joaillier
est donc très vite il va créer cette
cette entreprise volot gaulle à l'époque
et prend un logo alors il est aussi
passionné de rose
alors attendez parce que si on regarde
bien vous l'avez constaté sur ce qu'on
vient de voir à l'instinct et l'audio
petit et cuisson sur le logo il ya une
rose c'était exactement c'est toujours
d'ailleurs
l'emblème de chez l'oncle chez lancôme
parce qu'il est mêlé rose alors il était
passionné de rose et il aura d'ailleurs
une grande roseraie donc là dans son
premier logo puisque ça va évoluer au
cours des années vous avez la rose qui
représente le parfum vous avez la fleur
de lotus qui représente plutôt le soin
et puis l'an chinois qui représente le
maquillage
je crois même qu à une rose lancôme je
dis ça et oui qui adore les roses dont
un célèbre rosiéristes en bourgogne
franche comté invitera d'ailleurs
peut-être un de ces jours pour la fête
des mamans parce que ça vaut le détour
il ya la rose long comme alors cédé le
bar qui va créer cette rose lancôme dont
vous voyez avec un peu viol est un peu
pourpre et qui est très parfumé et donc
ça se trouve dans l'allier à la maison
delbarre se trouve dans l'allier à
malicorne et à peu près très peu de
planck derosier lancôme qui sortent tous
les ans mais elle est toujours
elle est toujours présente je sais
qu'entre autres patients monsieur
l'avocat
vous aimez les fleurs et je vous vois
vous le fan de jardin loucher sur marie
thérèse que vous connaissiez la rose
lancôme
absolument pas mais je la trouve
magnifique et je trouve qu'on a des très
belles histoires humaines en bourgogne
franche comté
c'est chouette mais franchement très
très belle rose la marque qui a eu aussi
de nombreuses valeurs ça ne risque pas
que la rose il ya plein de personnalité
c'est oui alors on a les françaises on
va dire cristiana reali on a l'âge
alors madame céline et geslin que
j'avais croisé une fois que oui et
penelope cruz et puis surtout tous les
rôles
voilà je viens kate winslet aussi élevé
julia roberts qui va faire beaucoup pour
la marque lancôme à kate winslet surtout
le cas d'alain et c'est vrai qu'elles
ont bien valorisé aussi cette maison est
juste je voudrais revenir sur le haut de
lancôme parce que pourquoi l'accent
circonflexe qui donne donc un côté chic
et donc sera le haut de lancôme on aura
hypnose toujours avec la cense conflit
qui va faire un petit peu la marque de
communication de la maison lancôme
aujourd'hui l'oréal a été racheté en pal
hors jeu la maison donc armand petitjean
blanc comme par north été rachetée c'est
pas le real a été racheté jeudi la
réponse dans la question voilà l'oréal a
racheté en 1964 entre-temps armand
petitjean notre franc comtois avait
transmis à son fils et cette année la
maison lancôme fêtera au mois de juillet
les 85 ans de la création et saint loup
sur semouse va fêter les 50 ans de ça
fait cinquante ans que armand petitjean
est décédé donc il devrait y avoir une
manifestation pas très loin de chez vous
et blanc l'oas alors que l'on commet la
fêtera donc en juillet 2020 à paris ses
85 ans d'existence et puis aussi plus
ponctuelle on doit un franc comtois a
salué sur semouse en haute saône